Alice:Lucy啊你在吗
Alice: Lucia, are you there?
Lucia: 我在二楼
Lucia: I'm on the second floor.
Alice:我来帮你吧
Alice: Let me help you.
Lucia: 可以呀谢谢你
Lucia: Sure, thanks.
Lucia: 还有你还有找到多的剪刀吗
Lucia: By the way, did you find any more scissors?
Alice:没有哎
Alice: No, I haven't.
Lucia: 因为我现在需要把这些都剪下来
Lucia: Because I need to cut all these now.
Lucia: 这眼镜怎么老往下掉烦死了
Lucia: These glasses keep slipping down, it's so annoying.
Alice:那你那个不好用的剪刀呢
Alice: What about those bad scissors?
Alice:你找到了吗
Alice: Did you find them?
Lucia: 不好用的那个没有
Lucia: The bad ones? No.
Lucia: 我只在快递桌上找到了这个
Lucia: I only found these on the delivery table.
Lucia: 就是昨天晚上我用的那个
Lucia: The ones I used last night.
Alice:哎这不是吗
Alice: Oh, isn't this it?
Lucia: 嗯哎可以的可以的
Lucia: Yeah, this one works, it works.
Lucia: 对对对就是那个
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, that's the one.
Lucia: 那可能是昨天雨轩在楼上用了这个
Lucia: Maybe Yuxuan used it upstairs yesterday.
Alice:你的吗
Alice: Is it yours?
Lucia: 不是我的
Lucia: It's not mine.
Lucia: 这是雨轩的
Lucia: It's Yuxuan's.
Alice:是啥呀
Alice: What is it?
Lucia: 他是想做一个风铃
Lucia: He wanted to make a wind chime.
Lucia: 他还没做完应该
Lucia: He probably hasn't finished it yet.
Lucia: 不过我我跟他确实有个很像的配件看
Lucia: But I do have a very similar part, look.
Lucia: 我就还没有把它拆下来做装饰
Lucia: I just haven't taken it apart to use as decoration.
Alice:好像那个含香头上戴的那个
Alice: It looks like the one Hanxiang wears on her head.
Lucia: 因为这个
Lucia: Because this
Lucia: 啊是对对对
Lucia: Ah, yes, yes.
Alice:香妃
Alice: Xiangfei.
Lucia: 因为我这个珠子
Lucia: Because these beads,
Lucia: 打算等欧根纱到了再用的
Lucia: I plan to use them when the organza arrives.
Alice:欧根纱到了吗
Alice: Has the organza arrived?
Lucia: 总感觉我
Lucia: I feel like
Alice:今天可以做吗
Alice: Can we do it today?
Lucia: 到了
Lucia: It has arrived.
Lucia: 总感觉我给自己挖了一个很大的坑
Lucia: I feel like I've dug myself a big hole.
Alice:你你这个有镭射的感觉好看
Alice: This one with the laser effect looks nice.
Lucia: 对是的他镀了膜
Lucia: Yeah, it's coated.
Lucia: 可以帮我把这些都剪下来吗
Lucia: Can you help me cut all these?
Lucia: 就是嗯我看我怎么跟你解释一下
Lucia: I mean, let me explain it to you.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Lucia: 这样就比较好搞
Lucia: This way it's easier to handle.
Lucia: 就是你看他其实每个每个贴画
Lucia: You see, each sticker,
Lucia: 他本来是这样的
Lucia: It was originally like this.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 然后但因为就是不敢这样往墙上贴吗
Lucia: But because I'm scared to stick it on the wall like this
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: So
Lucia: 所以我就是沿着它这个边给它剪下来
Lucia: I just cut it along the edge
Lucia: 也不用剪的特别齐
Lucia: It doesn't need to be cut perfectly
Lucia: 就是只要这个画在上面就行
Lucia: As long as the picture is on it, it's fine
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then
Lucia: 对就我到时候用美文纸往上一贴
Lucia: I just stick it on with some decorative paper
Lucia: 谢谢你因为这个工作量真的有点大
Lucia: Thank you, because this is quite a big task
Lucia: 你看我已经剪了一个
Lucia: See, I've already cut one
Alice:但如果我剪的不是特别顺呢
Alice: But what if I don't cut it perfectly?
Lucia: 呃没事就只要
Lucia: Uh, it's fine, as long as
Alice:只要画在上就行
Alice: As long as the picture is on it, it's fine
Lucia: 对对我觉得只要画在上面就行
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I think as long as the picture is on it, it's fine
Alice:那直接按照这个缝剪得了
Alice: Then I'll just cut along this seam
Lucia: 就你看我这个
Lucia: Look at mine
Lucia: 对对对就按那个份剪
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, just cut along that seam
Lucia: 然后你偏一点或者怎么样都没关系的
Lucia: Even if you're a bit off, it's okay
Lucia: 因为反正只是大概的用一下
Lucia: Because we're just roughly using it
Lucia: 现在已经
Lucia: Right now
Lucia: 没有空间就是让我们再去进行一些
Lucia: We don't have space for perfectionism
Lucia: 强迫症的就是完美主义了啊
Lucia: We can't be obsessive perfectionists anymore
Alice:我懂你的意思
Alice: I get what you mean
Lucia: 每次都会感激的要感到崩溃
Lucia: Every time, I feel grateful to the point of breaking down
Lucia: 谢谢可心
Lucia: Thank you, Kexin
Alice:51之后还会再录一期吗
Alice: Will there be another recording after May 1st?
Lucia: 呃不知道也有可能
Lucia: Uh, not sure, maybe
Lucia: 有可能只是靖康他们在开玩笑
Lucia: Maybe Jingkang was just joking
Lucia: 因为那个
Lucia: Because
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh
Lucia: 就是薇薇说他们那边就是三亚那边
Lucia: ViVi said that in Sanya
Lucia: 房子租金很便宜
Lucia: The rent there is very cheap
Lucia: 很便宜
Lucia: Very cheap
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed
Lucia: 就是咱们这个不是租一天要1,500吗
Lucia: Unlike here, where renting a place costs 1,500 a day
Lucia: 唉不愧是北京啊
Lucia: Ah, Beijing is something else
Alice:我打算
Alice: I'm planning
Alice:我打算去大理旅游一个月旅居一个月
Alice: I'm planning to travel to Dali for a month, live there for a month
Lucia: 哇我我可以申请和你一起去吗
Lucia: Wow, can I apply to go with you?
Alice:但是我还得看那个行程安排
Alice: But I still need to check my schedule
Alice:因为我学校也不是完全能走脱
Alice: Because I can't completely leave school.
Alice:然后我现在打算
Alice: And now I'm planning to...
Lucia: 出去玩可以找我
Lucia: If you want to go out, you can ask me.
Lucia: 我在理论上说
Lucia: I mean, theoretically...
Lucia: 我在今年8月之前
Lucia: Before August this year...
Lucia: 应该整体安排都不是很忙
Lucia: I shouldn't be too busy overall.
Lucia: 就是时间会相对自由一些
Lucia: So I'll have a relatively free schedule.
Lucia: 除非有一些会什么的之类要开
Lucia: Unless there are some meetings or something.
Lucia: 就学校的那种
Lucia: Like school-related ones.
Lucia: 所以如果出去玩可以找大理我也没去过
Alice:大理是个很美的城市
Alice: Dali is a very beautiful city.
Lucia: 国内很多地方都没去过
Lucia: There are many places in the country I haven't been to.
Lucia: 如果他们接下来要在三亚搞也挺好的
Lucia: If they're going to hold something in Sanya next, that'd be great.
Lucia: 我就继续报名
Lucia: I'll sign up again.
Lucia: 因为三亚我也没去过
Lucia: Because I haven't been to Sanya either.
Alice:只不过就是很热
Alice: It's just very hot.
Alice:但是我们不怎么外出的话
Alice: But if we don't go out much...
Alice:只是费点电而已
Alice: It'll just cost a bit more electricity.
Lucia: 我觉得按照咱们这次的这个安排
Lucia: I think, based on our current plan...
Lucia: 看起来不是很会经常外出
Lucia: It doesn't look like we'll be going out often.
Alice:想听歌露西
Alice: Lucia, want to listen to some music?
Alice:我放一首歌吧
Alice: I'll play a song.
Alice:你听中文吗
Alice: Do you listen to Chinese music?
Lucia: 我没事都可以听
Lucia: I can listen to anything.
Alice:我喜欢听这个
Alice: I like this one.
Lucia: 我只是因为
Lucia: It's just that...
Lucia: 我自己比较喜欢的那几个歌手
Lucia: The artists I like...
Lucia: 是外国的
Lucia: Are mostly foreign.
Lucia: 所以我就听欧美的听得多一些
Lucia: So I listen to more Western music.
Lucia: 但是其实只是听的话
Lucia: But actually, if it's just listening...
Lucia: 我什么都可以听的
Lucia: I can listen to anything.
Lucia: 我觉得我小装饰好像买的太少了
Lucia: I think I bought too few decorations.
Lucia: 我当时害怕到不了
Lucia: I was afraid they wouldn't arrive.
Lucia: 觉得没有必要买那么多
Lucia: I thought there was no need to buy too many.
Lucia: 现在看来
Lucia: Now it seems...
Lucia: 可能会导致那个房间稍微有点单调
Lucia: It might make the room look a bit plain.
Alice:我当时本来有很多想买的小东西
Alice: I had many small items I wanted to buy.
Alice:但我后来想
Alice: But then I thought...
Alice:我们的预算有限
Alice: Our budget is limited.
Alice:然后那种小的可能看不见
Alice: And those small items might not be noticeable.
Alice:然后我就买了大件的那个床单被罩
Alice: So then I bought a large set of bed sheets and duvet cover.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:然后窗帘这种
Alice: And then curtains and stuff.
Lucia: 我这有一个很重
Lucia: I have something really heavy here.
Lucia: 要的
Lucia: That I need.
Lucia: 预算花在我买了一个小塑料柜上
Lucia: I spent my budget on a small plastic cabinet.
Lucia: 虽然那个它也不是很贵
Lucia: Although it wasn't very expensive either.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But.
Lucia: 因为我那个房间不是没有小小桌子
Lucia: Because my room didn't have a small table.
Lucia: 它是一个特别丑的架子
Lucia: It had a really ugly shelf.
Lucia: 你来看真的很丑
Lucia: You should see it, it's really ugly.
Lucia: 我房间现还有点还有点乱
Lucia: My room is still a bit messy right now.
Alice:你当初
Alice: Back then,
Alice:为什么一开始就想选这个房间呢
Alice: why did you choose this room in the first place?
Lucia: 我想选个二楼的
Lucia: I wanted to pick one on the second floor.
Lucia: 然后随便就随便进了一个
Lucia: And then I just randomly went into one.
Lucia: 因为我
Lucia: Because I...
Alice:这个是架子吗对
Alice: Is this the shelf? Right.
Lucia: 对就他很丑
Lucia: Yes, it's really ugly.
Lucia: 所以我就买了一个那个小柜
Lucia: So I bought a small cabinet.
Lucia: 到时候我就把这个搬出去嗯
Lucia: Later, I'll move this one out.
Alice:啊你的渔网
Alice: Ah, your fishing net.
Alice:小写生活大写爱
Alice: Small life, big love.
Lucia: 然后那边理论上用欧根纱
Lucia: And over there, theoretically, I'll use organza.
Lucia: 做一个海浪形状的装饰
Lucia: To make a wave-shaped decoration.
Lucia: 假如今天还来得及的话
Lucia: If there's still time today.
Alice:是呢这样一铺就好多了
Alice: Yes, it looks much better like this.
Lucia: 然后这个架子
Lucia: And this shelf.
Lucia: 下午我就把它搬到客厅去放这
Lucia: I'll move it to the living room this afternoon.
Lucia: 然后这个其实我有点想再往这边拿
Lucia: And actually, I kind of want to move it over here.
Alice:哎你的欧根纱多不多啊
Alice: Hey, do you have much organza left?
Lucia: 呃估计不是很多
Lucia: Uh, probably not much.
Lucia: 我好像买了一米半
Lucia: I think I bought a meter and a half.
Lucia: 你要干嘛
Lucia: What do you want to do?
Alice:欧根纱往这边缠一缠是不是也会
Alice: If we wrap the organza around here, wouldn't it look good?
Lucia: 哦没事这个直接拿出去到时候嘿嘿
Lucia: Oh, no worries, I'll just take this out later, hehe.
Alice:就是显得也还好
Alice: It would look fine, right?
Alice:我的小礼物
Alice: My little gift.
Lucia: 嘿嘿
Lucia: Hehe.
Lucia: 我打算把它挂在这个网上
Lucia: I plan to hang it on this net.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:也挺好
Alice: It's pretty good.
Lucia: 形成一个时光墙的感觉
Lucia: It creates a kind of time wall feeling.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:你是不是不怎么带装饰
Alice: You don't wear much jewelry, do you?
Lucia: 呃哪个装饰哦
Lucia: Uh, which jewelry?
Lucia: 你说我哦
Lucia: Are you talking about me?
Alice:你的极简主义
Alice: Your minimalist style.
Lucia: 你说平常没有不是
Lucia: You mean usually, no, right?
Lucia: 我也带
Lucia: I do wear it.
Lucia: 但是就是出门的话我会觉得很麻烦
Lucia: But when going out, I find it troublesome.
Lucia: 然后因为
Lucia: And because...
Lucia: 尤其咱们其实在这里住几天嘛
Lucia: Especially since we're staying here for a few days.
Lucia: 然后我就会觉得很麻烦
Lucia: So, I find it troublesome.
Lucia: 我就不怎么带了
Lucia: I don't wear much.
Lucia: 我在家的话会带
Lucia: At home, I do wear it.
Lucia: 因为我总会觉得就是我要是带了
Lucia: Because I always feel like if I wear it,
Lucia: 我还得就是关注着他
Lucia: I have to pay attention to it.
Lucia: 比如说什么洗脸啊
Lucia: Like when washing my face or whatever.
Lucia: 或者什么的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Alice:是的我干什么这个
Alice: Yes, I do the same.
Lucia: 有时候我可能
Lucia: Sometimes I might...
Alice:我就不想让他碰到水
Alice: I just don't want it to touch water.
Lucia: 对然后可能个别的时候很需要摘他
Lucia: Right, and sometimes it's necessary to take it off.
Lucia: 但你摘了你要专门寄然后放在哪里了
Lucia: But if you take it off, you need to store it properly.
Lucia: 给他带盒子什么的
Lucia: Bring a box for it or something.
Lucia: 然后我觉得很麻烦我就不带
Lucia: I find it troublesome, so I don't wear it.
Lucia: 我这人特别懒
Lucia: I'm really lazy.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你可
Lucia: Haha, you might not have seen anyone lazier than me.
Lucia: 你可能都没有见过比我更懒的人了
Lucia: Really.
Lucia: 真的
Lucia: Seriously.
Alice:懒人有懒福
Alice: Lazy people have their blessings.
Lucia: 我真的超级懒然
Lucia: I'm really super lazy.
Lucia: 后就导致我每次干事情
Lucia: It leads to me always doing things
Lucia: 都会都会凑到DDL的时候干
Lucia: At the last minute.
Alice:我现在觉得很多事情是注定
Alice: I feel like many things are predestined.
Lucia: 一定程度上确实
Lucia: To a certain extent, that's true.
Lucia: 我觉得像这种小的
Lucia: For small things like this,
Lucia: 我都可以直接直接粘
Lucia: I can just stick them directly.
Lucia: 我把它在某个纸上
Lucia: I'll put it on some paper
Lucia: 那样先粘一下
Lucia: Then stick it first
Lucia: 然后撕下来
Lucia: And then tear it off
Lucia: 它的胶性就会变弱
Lucia: Its stickiness will weaken
Alice:哇会呀
Alice: Wow, it works
Lucia: 就像这种来浪的这个
Lucia: Just like this one, ride the wave
Lucia: 好困
Lucia: 就撕下
Lucia: 扔到这里
Lucia: And throw it here
Alice:（歌词）我会永远爱你
Alice: (Singing) I will always love you
Lucia: 对这个星星我就那样子刷
Lucia: Yes, I'll just brush this star like this
Alice:我去西安的话我去找你玩吧
Alice: If I go to Xi'an, I'll look for you to hang out
Lucia: 可以啊来来来
Lucia: Sure, come, come
Lucia: 你什么时候来
Lucia: When are you coming?
Alice:我可能还要去找一下我朋友
Alice: I might need to find my friend too
Alice:他在好像不在西安
Alice: He seems to not be in Xi'an
Alice:还在吗哎不在吧
Alice: Is he still there? No, he's not
Lucia: 前段时间
Lucia: Recently
Lucia: 我有一个小伙伴刚来西安找过我
Lucia: A friend of mine just came to Xi'an to visit me
Alice:在西北农林西北农林在咸阳
Alice: Northwest A&F, Northwest A&F is in Xianyang
Lucia: 不太了解
Lucia: Not very familiar
Alice:西北农林科技
Alice: Northwest A&F University
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because
Lucia: 我其实一般也就在我们家附近那一片
Lucia: I usually just stay around my neighborhood
Lucia: 而且
Lucia: And
Lucia: 因为就是我上学期没有在西安上嘛
Lucia: Because I wasn't in Xi'an last semester
Lucia: 所以感觉有的地方也不是特别的熟
Lucia: So I don't know some places that well
Lucia: 他们那边现在像北京一样
Lucia: Now their place is like Beijing
Lucia: 就是专门在有一个区北边
Lucia: There's a special northern district
Lucia: 那是什么区啊
Lucia: What's that district called?
Lucia: 那边就是在就是比较远的一个区
Lucia: It's quite far, a remote district
Lucia: 给很多学校盖了分校
Lucia: They built many branch schools there
Lucia: 觉得就很麻烦
Lucia: It's quite inconvenient
Lucia: 把学生搞那么远地方去上学
Lucia: Sending students so far to study
Lucia: 一点体验都没有
Lucia: There's no experience at all
Lucia: 下午还要叠被子
Lucia: I still have to fold my quilt this afternoon
Lucia: 可是为什么你的卧室那么整齐
Lucia: But why is your bedroom so tidy?
Lucia: 你把行李放在哪里了哈哈哈
Lucia: Where did you put your luggage? Haha
Alice:行李箱里面
Alice: In the suitcase
Lucia: 我现在有点后悔
Lucia: I'm kind of regretting now
Lucia: 我带的行李有点多
Lucia: I brought too much luggage
Lucia: 我怕冷我带了我就多带了外套
Lucia: I was afraid of the cold, so I brought an extra coat.
Lucia: 但是到了以后发现其实也不冷
Lucia: But after arriving, I found it wasn't cold at all.
Lucia: 实际上并不冷
Lucia: Actually, it's not cold.
Lucia: 这个星星你就随便剪一下吧
Lucia: You can just cut this star casually.
Lucia: 这星星我一会把它胶性弄弱一点
Lucia: I'll weaken the adhesive on this star a bit.
Lucia: 然后直接摘
Lucia: Then we can just remove it.
Alice:完美呀
Alice: Perfect.
Lucia: 啊好看
Lucia: Ah, it looks good.
Lucia: 我刚才也剪了一个海鸥
Lucia: I just cut a seagull too.
Alice:这个你剪完了
Alice: Did you finish this one?
Lucia: 对这个因为比较大
Lucia: Yes, because it's quite big.
Lucia: 然后如果你觉得有需要
Lucia: And if you think it's necessary,
Lucia: 就是修的边可以修一修
Lucia: you can trim the edges a bit.
Lucia: 因为那个是昨天
Lucia: Because yesterday,
Lucia: 其实我没有找到剪刀
Lucia: I couldn't find the scissors.
Lucia: 就是那个那个不太好用的蓝剪刀
Lucia: The blue scissors weren't working well.
Lucia: 雨轩当时在做那个风铃
Lucia: Yuxuan was making the wind chime then,
Lucia: 然后我就就是顺手用手撕了一下
Lucia: so I just tore it with my hands.
Lucia: 因为反正当时咱们坐在这开会
Lucia: Since we were having a meeting here anyway.
Lucia: 没事干嘛
Lucia: Nothing else to do.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 我还我的预算还花在一个小玩偶上
Lucia: I also spent my budget on a small toy.
Lucia: 我买了一只蓝色的小鸟
Lucia: I bought a little blue bird.
Lucia: 也是jellycat的
Lucia: It's also from Jellycat.
Lucia: 不过会便宜一些
Lucia: But it was cheaper.
Lucia: 因为它体积比较小
Lucia: Because it's smaller.
Alice:你们是不是都比较喜欢Jellycat
Alice: Do you all like Jellycat?
Alice:Jellycat它的吸引力在哪里
Alice: What's the appeal of Jellycat?
Alice:我不我不是质疑我就是单纯的疑问
Alice: I'm not questioning it, just curious.
Lucia: 他比较可爱吧
Lucia: It's pretty cute, I guess.
Lucia: 然后我家里其实有一个他的小狗
Lucia: I actually have a small dog from Jellycat at home.
Lucia: 我当时买的时候
Lucia: When I bought it,
Lucia: 他现在还没有现在这么火
Lucia: it wasn't as popular as it is now.
Lucia: 我当时在英国
Lucia: I was in the UK then.
Lucia: 然后是他出了一个柯基小狗的玩具
Lucia: And they had released a corgi toy.
Lucia: 我觉得很可爱
Lucia: I thought it was really cute.
Lucia: 我在那个哈罗德逛街
Lucia: I was shopping at Harrods.
Lucia: 因为哈罗德的东西太贵了我买不起
Lucia: Since everything at Harrods is so expensive, I couldn't afford anything else.
Lucia: 然后就只有玩具还便宜一点
Lucia: Only the toys were somewhat affordable.
Lucia: 我就买了一个
Lucia: So I bought one.
Lucia: 那个小狗真的挺软的挺舒服的
Lucia: That puppy is really soft and comfortable.
Lucia: 但我觉得这个鸟
Lucia: But I think this bird...
Lucia: 可能是因为它小的缘故
Lucia: Maybe because it's small...
Lucia: 就是它手感没有那个小狗好
Lucia: It doesn't feel as good as the puppy.
Lucia: 就是但是我买它是因为它是蓝色的
Lucia: But I bought it because it's blue.
Lucia: 就是它是蓝白相间那种颜色
Lucia: It's blue and white, that kind of color.
Lucia: 然后我把床铺好之后往床上一放
Lucia: Then after I made the bed and put it on...
Lucia: 就算是我装饰过床了
Lucia: It's like I've decorated my bed.
Lucia: 因为我实在是找不到好看的床罩
Lucia: Because I really can't find a good-looking bedspread.
Lucia: 我本来还想就是买一个
Lucia: I was originally thinking of buying one...
Lucia: 就是那个宾馆的那种
Lucia: Like the ones they have in hotels.
Lucia: 就是那样一条的那个东西
Lucia: You know, that strip of fabric.
Lucia: 我也不知道它叫什么
Lucia: I don't know what it's called.
Lucia: 就是每就是
Lucia: Just every...
Alice:呃
Alice: Uh...
Lucia: 每次去住宾馆他还不是给你铺好床
Lucia: Every time you stay at a hotel, they make the bed for you.
Lucia: 他会还在上面放一个一条
Lucia: They put a strip of fabric on top.
Alice:那个那个押押押金哎不知道
Alice: The... the... the security deposit, I don't know.
Lucia: 压压压惊
Lucia: It's just to make it look nice.
Lucia: 哎不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 对对对就就就是那个东西
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's it.
Lucia: 对反正你反正你肯定get到了
Lucia: Anyway, you get it.
Lucia: 就那个东西
Lucia: That thing.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Alice:我一直不知道那个东西是干啥的
Alice: I've never known what that thing is for.
Lucia: 我也不知道那用来干啥的
Lucia: I don't know what it's for either.
Alice:但是反正好看一点
Alice: But it looks nicer.
Lucia: 对我本来是想买一个蓝色那个东西
Lucia: Yes, I originally wanted to buy a blue one.
Lucia: 但是我发现
Lucia: But I found...
Lucia: 连那个好看的颜色都很难找
Lucia: Even finding a good color is hard.
Lucia: 就
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 我本来想哪怕是就是克莱因蓝也可以
Lucia: I thought even Klein blue would be fine.
Lucia: 虽然饱和度高一点
Lucia: Although it's a bit more saturated.
Lucia: 但是就整体它的色调上我觉得还是还
Lucia: But overall, I think it still matches.
Lucia: 是那个就是相符的但也没找到
Lucia: But I couldn't find it either.
Lucia: 然后我就就放弃了
Lucia: So I just gave up.
Alice:你要是用加装的标准来找
Alice: If you're looking with such high standards...
Alice:那就是基本是没
Alice: It's almost impossible.
Alice:的然后你可以搜关键词的时候
Alice: You can try searching for props.
Alice:可以搜摆拍道具啊
Alice: Look for "staging props" or something.
Lucia: 嗯
Alice:就是非家装的
Lucia: 我的我的镭射纸就是摆拍道具
Lucia: 希望他一会好用
Lucia: 好有道理
Lucia: 对摆拍道具
Lucia: 可我想赶快把这弄完
Lucia: 这样
Lucia: 我就可以把我的那个小水母做出来了
Lucia: 虽然今天他没有灯
Lucia: 但是呢
Alice:你们比较喜欢我这种人吗
Alice:啊你们比较喜欢我这种人吗
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: 为什么会不喜欢呢哈
Lucia: 我有好几个小伙伴都是EFP
Lucia: 而且我觉得你跟我一个朋友很像
Alice:NFP吗
Lucia: 就很对就很可爱
Lucia: 然后很怎么形容
Lucia: 就很很warm然后很很helpful的感觉
Lucia: 有谁会不喜欢呢
Lucia: Who wouldn't like it?
Lucia: 我觉得我们这种自闭哀人才比较
Lucia: I think people like us, who are introverted and melancholic,
Lucia: 才比较担心
Lucia: are more worried
Lucia: 就是就是别人喜不喜欢的问题
Lucia: about whether others like us or not.
Lucia: 因为感觉你们就是很热情
Lucia: Because you guys seem so enthusiastic,
Lucia: 所以大家肯定都会喜欢
Lucia: so everyone definitely likes you.
Alice:我以前觉得被人喜欢很重要
Alice: I used to think being liked by others was very important.
Alice:现在觉得被讨厌很正常
Alice: Now I think it's normal to be disliked.
Lucia: 哎我以前也觉得别人喜欢很重要
Lucia: Yeah, I used to think it was important for others to like me too.
Lucia: 但因为我是个哀  人
Lucia: But because I'm a melancholic person,
Lucia: 然后所以就是
Lucia: I feel like it's really hard for me
Lucia: 我觉得好像我也很难
Lucia: to be particularly, particularly,
Lucia: 就是特别特别特别
Lucia: particularly liked by everyone.
Alice:你的自我内心是很坚定的
Alice: Your inner self is very strong.
Alice:其实艺人有的时候
Alice: Actually, sometimes artists
Alice:对外界的反馈依赖感太强了
Alice: rely too much on external feedback.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:所以反而会
Alice: So in turn,
Lucia: 然后后来我就哎算了这个强求不来
Lucia: Eventually, I just thought, whatever, you can't force it.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上还在想
Lucia: I was still thinking about it last night.
Lucia: 今天活动我要不要戴你送的那个手链
Lucia: Should I wear the bracelet you gave me for today's event?
Alice:戴上吧
Lucia: 好的那我下午就戴上
Lucia: Okay, I'll wear it this afternoon.
Lucia: 这样就形成一个密切的集体感
Lucia: This will create a closer sense of community.
Alice:那个朱砂我给我最好的朋友也买了
Alice: I also bought that cinnabar bracelet for my best friend.
Lucia: 很好看
Lucia: It's so pretty.
Lucia: 谢谢可心
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Alice:也买了一条
Alice: I bought one too.
Alice:就是这是我送给他的新年礼物
Alice: This is my New Year's gift to him.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 好看的真的很好看
Lucia: It's really beautiful, so pretty.
Alice:因为他本命年了嘛
Alice: Because it's his zodiac year.
Alice:然后我就想着送他一个
Alice: So I thought I'd give him one.
Alice:就是这种辟邪的东西
Alice: Something to ward off evil spirits.
Alice:然后后来他他姥姥看见了
Alice: And then later, his grandmother saw it.
Alice:然后他就觉得
Alice: And she thought
Alice:他姥姥也觉得那个手链很好
Alice: that the bracelet was really nice too.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:然后寓意也好
Alice: And it has good meaning.
Alice:然后他他又托我买一条
Alice: So she asked me to buy another one.
Alice:然后我就给他姥姥也买了一条
Alice: So I bought one for his grandmother too.
Lucia: 人见人爱
Lucia: Everyone loves it.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This, this.
Lucia: 一会再弄他
Lucia: I'll deal with it later.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 我小时候特别想给自己家床上
Lucia: When I was a kid, I really wanted to put
Lucia: 不是自己家床上
Lucia: Not on my bed.
Lucia: 说啥呢我
Lucia: 我自己家墙上贴这个就是墙贴
Lucia: On my wall, I wanted to put these wall stickers.
Lucia: 让我爸妈觉得墙贴不好收拾
Lucia: But my parents thought wall stickers were hard to clean.
Lucia: 因为就有的墙贴如果你贴时间久了
Lucia: Because some wall stickers, if you leave them up too long,
Lucia: 他就不好撕嘛
Lucia: They're hard to peel off.
Lucia: 然后撕下来他可能就有那种黑印子
Lucia: And when you peel them off, they might leave black marks.
Lucia: 我爸妈比较洁癖
Lucia: My parents are kind of clean freaks.
Lucia: 也不能算是洁癖
Lucia: Well, not clean freaks.
Lucia: 就是他们比较喜欢房间整齐一点
Lucia: They just like the room to be neat and tidy.
Lucia: 然后我就一直没有贴过好可惜
Lucia: So I never got to put them up, such a pity.
Lucia: 这次也不能贴
Lucia: Can't put them up this time either.
Lucia: 好可惜只能拿美文纸贴一下
Lucia: Such a pity, I can only use decorative tape.
Lucia: 不过我觉得那美文纸还行
Lucia: But I think that Meiwen paper is okay.
Lucia: 还挺好用的
Lucia: It's pretty useful.
Alice:我小时候把我们家所有的家具上
Alice: When I was little, I wrote the number eleven on all our furniture.
Alice:都用我妈的口红写了一个十一
Alice: I used my mom's lipstick to write eleven everywhere.
Lucia: 啊为什么呢
Lucia: Ah, why?
Lucia: 为什么是十一呢
Lucia: Why the number eleven?
Alice:已经不记得了
Alice: I don't remember anymore.
Alice:但我就是把所有家具上面都画了个11
Alice: But I drew an eleven on every piece of furniture.
Alice:所有哈哈
Alice: Everywhere, haha.
Alice:毕竟我们家还是那种木
Alice: After all, our home was all wood.
Alice:呃实木家具
Alice: Solid wood furniture.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:就是那种
Alice: It's that kind of...
Alice:反正就是口红画上去
Alice: Anyway, once the lipstick was on it.
Alice:就基本别想弄掉了
Alice: You could basically never get it off.
Lucia: 怎么样弄掉了
Lucia: How did you get it off?
Lucia: 你怎么听起来好像
Lucia: You sound like...
Lucia: 哈哈我啊
Lucia: Haha, like me.
Alice:我我小时候还点房子呢点火
Alice: When I was little, I even set fire to the house.
Alice:在我把我家墙烧的黢黑
Alice: I burned the walls of our house black.
Lucia: 在啊
Lucia: Really?
Alice:然后小时候虎了吧唧的
Alice: I was a reckless kid.
Alice:我还偷邻居家的花
Alice: I even stole flowers from our neighbor.
Alice:其实我当时没想要偷
Alice: Actually, I didn't mean to steal.
Alice:我就觉得那么好看
Alice: I just thought they were so pretty.
Alice:我就想让它离我近一点
Alice: I wanted them closer to me.
Alice:然后我就把它拿了种在我家
Alice: So I took them and planted them in our garden.
Lucia: 我小时候
Lucia: When I was little...
Alice:种在我家的花坛里
Alice: Planted them in our garden.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 我小时候试图抓过邻居家的鸽子
Lucia: I tried to catch our neighbor's pigeons when I was little.
Lucia: 但我们我们家邻居没有花花
Lucia: But our neighbor didn't have any flowers.
Lucia: 我爸在阳台上养过花花
Lucia: My dad used to grow flowers on the balcony.
Lucia: 后来他也不养
Lucia: But he stopped.
Lucia: 他嫌麻烦
Lucia: He thought it was troublesome.
Alice:这个空白就不给你剪了吧
Alice: Let's not cut this empty part.
Alice:你直接这样一整一个整体
Alice: Just keep it all together.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 让他放在墙上
Lucia: Let's put it on the wall.
Lucia: 没有那个啥
Lucia: There's nothing else.
Lucia: 因为他这个底本来是透明的
Lucia: Because the base was originally transparent.
Lucia: 但是现在不能给他弄透明了
Lucia: But now we can't make it transparent.
Lucia: 咱们剪下来它肯定是白色的
Lucia: If we cut it, it will definitely be white.
Lucia: 哎呀我觉得这个头发
Lucia: Oh, I think this hair...
Lucia: 他怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on with it?
Lucia: 他一直在挡着这个
Lucia: It's always blocking this.
Alice:哎呀我怎么红灯了快快快
Alice: Oh no, why is it a red light? Hurry, hurry!
Lucia: 啊我的还亮着没
Lucia: Ah, is mine still on?
Lucia: 我没充那充电宝
Lucia: I didn't charge the power bank.
Alice:亮着呢
Alice: It's on.
Lucia: 哦那就好
Lucia: Oh, that's good.
Lucia: 我一会下楼把我的线拿上充一个
Lucia: I'll go downstairs to get my cable and charge it later.
Lucia: 我线放哪我都不记得了我靠
Lucia: Where did I put my cable? I don't remember, damn.
Lucia: 好尴尬
Lucia: So embarrassing.
Lucia: 可心打算什么时候去玩呀
Lucia: When are you planning to go out and have fun?
Alice:我在想我接下来的安排
Alice: I'm thinking about my upcoming plans.
Lucia: 给你当向导
Lucia: I'll be your guide.
Lucia: 你们是这学期课少吗还是
Lucia: Do you guys have fewer classes this semester, or...?
Alice:对我基本上我的课都在研一上完了
Alice: Yes, I basically finished all my classes in the first year of my master's.
Alice:并且我研一的时候因为我是跨专业
Alice: And because I switched majors in the first year,
Alice:我还要补修三门
Alice: I had to take three additional courses.
Alice:我的课真是上的够够的
Alice: I've had enough of classes.
Alice:这辈子不会再想上一门课
Alice: I never want to take another class in my life.
Lucia: 哎所以你本科学的是
Lucia: So, what was your undergraduate major?
Alice:物联网
Alice: Internet of Things.
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Lucia: 你那天自我介绍时候讲过
Lucia: You mentioned it during your self-introduction that day.
Alice:其我觉得自己很聪明
Alice: Actually, I think I'm pretty smart.
Lucia: 你就是很聪明呀
Lucia: You are very smart.
Lucia: 因为我感觉跨专业还是挺难的
Lucia: I feel like switching majors is quite challenging.
Alice:是的并且我没有报班
Alice: Yes, and I didn't take any classes.
Alice:我是买的书自己看着考的
Alice: I bought the books and studied for the exams myself.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's impressive.
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Alice:也没有人教我
Alice: And no one taught me.
Lucia: 那你是为什么转成语言学呀
Lucia: So, why did you switch to linguistics?
Lucia: 是自己比较喜欢吗
Lucia: Is it because you like it more?
Alice:觉得比较有意思
Alice: I find it more interesting.
Alice:我就想换个专业读
Alice: I just wanted to study a different major.
Lucia: 哎我也是
Lucia: I'm the same way.
Alice:我就想去文科看一看
Alice: I just want to check out the humanities department.
Lucia: 我本科就学的金融然后
Lucia: I studied finance for my undergrad and...
Alice:你喜欢吗
Alice: Do you like it?
Lucia: 嗯本来我觉得还是有点喜欢的吧
Lucia: Hmm, at first, I kind of liked it.
Lucia: 但是学了之后发现其实并不喜欢
Lucia: But after studying it, I realized I didn't really like it.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And...
Alice:就你做的很有限
Alice: You felt it was very limited.
Alice:你能做的
Alice: What you could do...
Lucia: 对我觉得我不是因为金融很卷
Lucia: Yeah, I think it's because finance is very competitive.
Lucia: 然后我觉得我不是一个很卷的人
Lucia: And I don't think I'm a competitive person.
Lucia: 我不喜欢卷
Lucia: I don't like the competition.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: It's just... just...
Alice:我也是
Alice: Me neither.
Lucia: 我觉得除非是那种就是真的你喜欢卷
Lucia: I think unless you're someone who really likes competition...
Lucia: 然后能量很高的那种人他才适合
Lucia: And has a lot of energy for it, it's suitable for them.
Lucia: 就是我是那种
Lucia: But for me...
Lucia: 如果非要卷我也可以卷一下
Lucia: If I have to compete, I can do it.
Lucia: 但是我不会自发的去卷
Lucia: But I wouldn't do it voluntarily.
Lucia: 所以如果时间久了
Lucia: So, over time...
Alice:就做了这件事之后
Alice: After doing it for a while...
Alice:你可能不会那么开心
Alice: You might not be that happy.
Lucia: 对然后时间长的话我觉得很累
Lucia: Yeah, and if it goes on for too long, I feel very tired.
Lucia: 我就算了
Lucia: So, I just gave up.
Alice:我当时转专业是因为
Alice: I switched majors because...
Alice:虽然我在转专业之前
Alice: Although before I switched majors...
Alice:我这个专业还是挺好的
Alice: My major was actually quite good.
Alice:毕竟算是物联网计算机那种的
Alice: It was in IoT and computer science, after all.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:我当时就觉得这个行业长久不了
Alice: But I felt this industry wouldn't last long.
Alice:我当时就觉得不出五年
Alice: I thought it wouldn't last more than five years.
Alice:他可能就要那啥了
Alice: It might just...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:然后并且我也不是一个
Alice: And also, I'm not a...
Alice:就是
Alice: Just...
Alice:其实我我觉得自己其实能做好的
Alice: Actually, I think I can do well in it.
Alice:因为
Alice: Because...
Alice:我其实如果纯看那个成绩排名的话
Alice: If you look purely at my grades, I was around fourth or fifth.
Alice:我基本上就是第四第五的那样子
Alice: But I just couldn't handle that job environment.
Alice:然后我觉得我就受不了那种就业环境
Alice: So I decided to switch.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:我觉得我一辈子
Alice: I feel like in my entire life,
Alice:让我耽误个三五年又算什么呢
Alice: What's the big deal if I waste three to five years?
Alice:我就真的需要找到自己很喜欢做的事
Alice: I really need to find something I love doing.
Alice:我为了一些就业的压力啊
Alice: Because of job pressure,
Alice:或者之类的什么别人的眼光
Alice: Or other people's opinions,
Alice:把自己先安置到一个
Alice: If I put myself in a position
Alice:自己其实并不喜欢的
Alice: I actually don't like,
Alice:位置上那一辈子都在痛苦
Alice: I would be miserable my whole life.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: True.
Alice:所以我觉得短期来看
Alice: So, I think in the short term,
Alice:这一两年确实没什么成就
Alice: For the past one or two years, I haven't achieved much.
Alice:没做成什么事
Alice: I haven't accomplished anything.
Alice:但是我一辈子几十年
Alice: But over my entire life,
Alice:我耽误个三五年又算什么
Alice: What's the big deal if I waste three to five years?
Alice:往就是等我比较老的时候
Alice: When I'm older and look back,
Alice:往回看
Alice: I'll see
Alice:就觉得这一点点时间根本不算什么
Alice: That this little bit of time is nothing.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: True.
Alice:无所谓我现在没有什么年龄焦虑
Alice: It doesn't matter. I have no age anxiety,
Alice:婚恋焦虑以及工作焦虑
Alice: No marriage or career anxiety.
Alice:什么时候都可以开始
Alice: I can start anytime.
Lucia: 虽然我现在学的
Lucia: Even though what I'm studying now
Lucia: 其实跟我本科也不是完全不一样
Lucia: Isn't completely different from my undergrad.
Lucia: 就我们我们本科专业叫经济与金融
Lucia: Our undergrad major was Economics and Finance,
Lucia: 所以就是它
Lucia: So, it's like
Lucia: 因为经济和金融本身它相关性就很高
Lucia: Economics and Finance are highly related.
Lucia: 然后其实是别的学校
Lucia: And actually, in other schools,
Lucia: 比如说对外经贸之类的金融学专业
Lucia: Like the University of International Business and Economics, their finance major,
Lucia: 它大一的专业课也要学很多经济学
Lucia: Also requires a lot of economics in the first year.
Lucia: 因为它是一个基础性的东西
Lucia: Because it's a fundamental subject.
Lucia: 金融好像是经济的二级学科
Lucia: Finance seems to be a sub-discipline of Economics
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 对然后
Lucia: Yeah, and then,
Lucia: 但我主要是觉得我在业界卷不来
Lucia: But mainly, I feel like I can't compete in the industry,
Lucia: 然后但又不是特别想搞学术研究
Lucia: And I'm not particularly interested in academic research either.
Lucia: 所以我硕士我念的是国际政治经济学
Lucia: So, for my master's, I studied International Political Economy,
Lucia: 就是他
Lucia: Which is like,
Lucia: 相当于是一个
Lucia: A crossover between
Lucia: 政治学和经济学的交叉学科
Lucia: Political Science and Economics.
Lucia: 但是他会其实会更偏文科一点
Lucia: But it leans more towards the humanities.
Lucia: 更偏社科一点对
Lucia: It's more inclined towards social sciences, right?
Lucia: 是那会对这个专业觉得比较感兴趣
Lucia: I was really interested in this major back then.
Lucia: 去学的但实际上
Lucia: So I went to study it, but actually...
Lucia: 实际上你说
Lucia: Actually, you know...
Lucia: 我是不是很想在这个专业
Lucia: Do I really want to do research in this field my whole life?
Lucia: 搞一辈子研究
Lucia: Or work in this field forever?
Lucia: 或者说一辈子从业
Lucia: I don't think so.
Lucia: 我觉得倒也不是
Lucia: 我就是喜欢干各种各样不一样的事情
Lucia: I just like doing different kinds of things.
Alice:那你博士的话你会申请什么呢
Alice: So, for your PhD, what would you apply for?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm...
Alice:还是在先等等结果
Alice: Or are you waiting for the results first?
Lucia: 我现在方向都跟我硕士方向差不多
Lucia: My current direction is pretty much the same as my master's.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm...
Lucia: 就是我申请的这几个
Lucia: So, for the ones I've applied for...
Lucia: 但我要等就是最后的就是结果出来
Lucia: I'll wait for the final results to see if I'm satisfied.
Lucia: 看我满不满意
Lucia: To see if I'm happy with it.
Lucia: 如果整体来说还算比较满意的话
Lucia: If overall I'm quite satisfied...
Lucia: 我应该会去先学一下
Lucia: 然后再看别的一些机会
Lucia: Then I'll look for some other opportunities.
Lucia: 因为我我就是
Lucia: Because I, I just...
Lucia: 我不觉得
Lucia: I don't think...
Lucia: 我好像是那种
Lucia: I'm the type...
Lucia: 会把自己一直限定在一个专业里面的
Lucia: To limit myself to just one field.
Lucia: 那种就像
Lucia: Like...
Lucia: 我其实特别喜欢跟我朋友去拍摄影啊
Lucia: I really enjoy taking photos with my friends and stuff.
Lucia: 或者之类这些
Lucia: Or things like that.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:露西亚
Alice: Lucia.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:相信我
Alice: Trust me.
Alice:你一定要在你的gap year
Alice: You must make the most of your gap year.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:就是就是
Alice: Like, really...
Alice:真的很要
Alice: It's very important.
Alice:要珍惜你脑子里一闪而过的念头
Alice: Cherish those fleeting thoughts in your mind.
Alice:真的
Alice: Really.
Lucia: 我跟他们拍了很多
Lucia: I've taken a lot with them.
Lucia: 就我不经常当模特或者之类的
Lucia: I don't often model or anything like that.
Lucia: 对然后
Lucia: Yeah, and then...
Lucia: 不不过我说了我这人很懒
Lucia: But I said I'm really lazy.
Lucia: 所以就是
Lucia: So, it's like
Lucia: 其实就算是模特的话我会觉得很累
Lucia: Even if I were a model, I'd feel really tired.
Lucia: 但是就是
Lucia: But still
Lucia: 我们最后把那个片子做出来的时候
Lucia: When we finally finish the video,
Lucia: 我会觉得
Lucia: I would feel
Lucia: 嗯很有成就感
Lucia: a great sense of accomplishment.
Alice:真的就是要用自己喜欢的方式
Alice: You really have to do it in a way you love.
Alice:就是一定要把自己
Alice: You definitely have to put yourself
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:处于一个滋养你的环境里面
Alice: in a nurturing environment.
Alice:然后你这个人的潜能才会被激发出来
Alice: That's when your potential will be brought out.
Alice:这是我的感觉
Alice: That's how I feel.
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:我现在觉得
Alice: I think now
Alice:很多事情就是你散发出的能量
Alice: a lot of things are about the energy you emit.
Alice:就是吸引力法则
Alice: It's the law of attraction.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice:想要什么就会有什么
Alice: Whatever you want, you'll get.
Lucia: 是这样的
Lucia: That's how it is.
Lucia: 这个星星星星
Lucia: These stars,
Lucia: 我打算到时候
Lucia: I'm planning to
Lucia: 直接就是在别的什么地方粘一粘
Lucia: stick them somewhere else first
Lucia: 让它粘性变差
Lucia: to reduce their stickiness,
Lucia: 然后直接往墙上粘
Lucia: and then stick them on the wall.
Alice:我可以帮你把星星给它剪下来
Alice: I can help you cut out the stars.
Lucia: 不想剪它了
Lucia: I don't want to cut them.
Lucia: 啊谢谢那也可以谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you, that works too, thanks.
Alice:搁这吧
Alice: Just put it here.
Lucia: 这个就不用剪他
Lucia: No need to cut this one.
Lucia: 这个是一个效果图
Lucia: This is just a sample.
Lucia: 就是你可以这样贴
Lucia: You can stick it like this.
Alice:这都是合格证啥的
Alice: These are all the certificates and stuff.
Lucia: 对对对然后那
Lucia: Yes, yes, and then
Alice:你记得别
Alice: Don't
Alice:那你别把这个扔了
Alice: Don't throw this away.
Lucia: 嘞我把这整理一下
Lucia: Sure, I'll tidy this up.
Lucia: 然后我去把头发稍微扎一下
Lucia: Then I'll tie my hair up a bit.
Lucia: 本来早晨就想扎
Lucia: I wanted to tie it up this morning,
Lucia: 但我觉得我好像事情搞不完了
Lucia: but I felt like I couldn't finish everything.
Lucia: 然后就没扎哎
Lucia: And then I didn't tie it up.
Lucia: 一辈子的拖延
Lucia: A lifetime of procrastination.
Lucia: 哈哈拖延症
Lucia: Haha, procrastination disorder.
Lucia: 永远的拖延症
Lucia: Eternal procrastination disorder.
Alice:说明你就是喜欢这样的生活节奏
Alice: It means you just like this kind of lifestyle.
Alice:生活方式呀
Alice: This way of living, right?
Lucia: 可能是因为虽然拖延
Lucia: Maybe it's because even though I procrastinate,
Lucia: 但是每次最后总是化险为夷的
Lucia: I always manage to get out of danger in the end.
Lucia: 把事情都干完了
Lucia: I get everything done.
Lucia: 然后就潜意识里就觉得没所谓了
Lucia: So subconsciously, I feel like it doesn't matter.
Lucia: 对反正总会干完的
Lucia: Yeah, it'll get done eventually anyway.
Lucia: 我这个一会可以粘一下了
Lucia: I can stick this on in a bit.
Lucia: 比划比划
Lucia: Let's measure it.
Lucia: 放在那先去把头发扎好
Lucia: Put it there first, then go tie my hair.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 我刚看他们有没有发什么哎
Lucia: I just checked if they sent anything.
Lucia: 谁给我打电话呀
Lucia: Who's calling me?
Lucia: 还是杭州
Lucia: It's still Hangzhou.
Lucia: 那可能是那个啥吧
Lucia: Maybe it's that thing.
Lucia: 可能是快递
Lucia: Maybe it's a delivery.
Lucia: 要不然怎么会有杭州电话
Lucia: Otherwise, why would I get a call from Hangzhou?
Lucia: 给我打电话
Lucia: Calling me.
Lucia: 啊这玩意一直在
Lucia: Ah, this thing is always here.
Lucia: （歌词）we don't know
Lucia: (singing) We don't know.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 雨轩已经把他的这个门把手安上了
Lucia: Yuxuan has already installed his door handle.
Lucia: 我现在特别好奇想要推开他的门
Lucia: Now I'm really curious to push his door open.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 感觉他那个设计也特别可爱
Lucia: His design is really cute too.
Lucia: 我今天看到他买的
Lucia: I saw the cute little accessories he bought today.
Lucia: 特别可爱的小配件了
Lucia: They are super cute.
Lucia: 感觉应该快了吧
Lucia: It should be soon, right?
Lucia: 哎不过取快递这个事
Lucia: Oh, but about picking up packages,
Lucia: 昨天我们去取快递
Lucia: We went to pick up a package yesterday,
Lucia: 取了一个小时
Lucia: and it took us an hour.
Lucia: 因为在路上去了一家彩票店
Lucia: Because we went to a lottery store on the way.
Alice:因为我窗帘还没有弄
Alice: Because I haven't done my curtains yet.
Lucia: 你是要把那个窗帘换一下吗
Lucia: Are you going to change the curtains?
Lucia: 还是给他上面加一些东西
Lucia: Or add something to them?
Alice:啊换不了
Alice: Ah, I can't change them.
Alice:估计那个换的话太麻烦了
Alice: I guess changing it would be too much trouble.
Alice:我准备把那个原来的窗帘
Alice: I'm planning to just pull the old curtains
Alice:就扒拉到两边
Alice: to both sides.
Alice:尽量降低它的存在感
Alice: Try to minimize their presence.
Lucia: 啊有道理
Lucia: Ah, that makes sense.
Alice:然后我那个窗帘其实不遮光
Alice: And my curtain doesn't really block the light.
Alice:它就是一个装饰的
Alice: It's more of a decoration.
Alice:纱的蕾蕾
Alice: It's like a sheer lace.
Alice:蕾丝
Alice: Lace.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 我们是
Lucia: We are...
Lucia: 现在已经快12点了害怕
Lucia: It's almost midnight now, kinda scary.
Alice:我们的甜点还没做呢
Alice: We haven't made our dessert yet.
Lucia: 有昨天的提拉米苏
Lucia: We still have yesterday's tiramisu.
Lucia: 其实我们昨天晚上汉堡还剩两个
Lucia: Actually, there are two burgers left from last night.
Lucia: 我收拾桌子的时候发现
Lucia: I found them while cleaning the table.
Lucia: 会让你很后悔
Lucia: You'll regret it.
Lucia: 这个就可以了
Lucia: This will do.
Lucia: 然后这是剪的
Lucia: And this is cut.
Lucia: 感觉基本上还可以
Lucia: Feels pretty okay.
Lucia: 有边就有边吧不管了
Lucia: If there's an edge, so be it. Never mind.
Alice:还有吗
Alice: Any more?
Lucia: 好像没有了
Lucia: Seems like no more.
Lucia: 谢谢可欣
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Lucia: 那个字到底是应该念科
Lucia: How should we pronounce that character?
Lucia: 是医生吗
Lucia: Is it 'ke'?
Lucia: 还是
Lucia: Or 'yi sheng'?
Alice:科吧
Alice: Probably 'ke'.
Alice:我不在乎
Alice: I don't care.
Alice:随便随便怎么念
Alice: However you want to say it.
Lucia: 可以稍微修一下
Lucia: Can we trim it a bit?
Lucia: 这是昨天
Lucia: This is from yesterday.
Lucia: 这昨天晚上手撕的
Lucia: Torn it by hand last night.
Alice:这是一整串的吗
Alice: Is this a whole bunch?
Lucia: 对那个他
Lucia: Yeah, it was supposed to be...
Lucia: 本来我是想用它做水母的线的
Lucia: I was planning to use it for the jellyfish strings.
Lucia: 如果一会有空还可以做一做
Lucia: If we have time later, we can make it.
Lucia: 然后就是我买的比较长
Lucia: And it's quite long.
Lucia: 然后剩下的部分
Lucia: So the leftover part
Lucia: 就可以放在我的那个欧根纱里面
Lucia: can be placed in my organza.
Lucia: 让他
Lucia: Let him...
Lucia: 变得更闪一些
Lucia: Make it a bit shinier.
Lucia: 你那天有压那个花吗
Lucia: Did you press those flowers the other day?
Alice:没  没有
Alice: No, no I didn't.
Lucia: 如果有压应该好了
Lucia: If you had pressed them, it should be fine.
Lucia: 我压的不多
Lucia: I didn't press a lot.
Lucia: 我就压了几片
Lucia: I just pressed a few.
Lucia: 因为感觉不知道能不能压成功
Lucia: Because I wasn't sure if it would work.
Lucia: 一会下去看看
Lucia: Let's check it out later.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: It's done.
Lucia: 非常感谢
Lucia: Thank you so much.
Lucia: 要是你不帮我剪的话
Lucia: If you hadn't helped me cut it,
Lucia: 我可能今天就剪不完了
Lucia: I wouldn't have finished it today.
Lucia: 剪完扔掉去
Lucia: Cut it and throw it away.
Lucia: 就用美容纸粘一下就可以了
Lucia: Just use some beauty paper to stick it.
Lucia: 边上这些不要了
Lucia: We don't need these edges.
Lucia: 这样一个效果图就可以了
Lucia: This sample image will do.
Lucia: 小的和小的放在一起
Lucia: Put the small ones together.
Lucia: 你觉得这个好看吗
Lucia: Do you think this looks good?
Lucia: 我感觉
Lucia: I feel...
Lucia: 他反而给我房间又增加了一个红色
Lucia: He ended up adding another red to my room
Lucia: 我本来只想要就是就是
Lucia: I originally just wanted, you know, just
Alice:纯蓝的
Alice: Pure blue
Lucia: 对对但是找不到那样的
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, but couldn't find anything like that
Alice:白蓝色
Alice: White and blue
Lucia: 就是像那个我之前去希腊玩的时候
Lucia: Like when I went to Greece before
Lucia: 他们有很多餐厅都装修成那样
Lucia: A lot of their restaurants are decorated like that
Lucia: 唉
Lucia: Sigh
Lucia: 现在发现那种风格还真不好装修呀
Lucia: Now I realize that style is really hard to decorate
Lucia: 本来以为可能也没有那么复杂的
Lucia: I thought it wouldn't be that complicated
Lucia: 把这个
Lucia: Put this
Lucia: 谢感谢
Lucia: Thanks, thank you
Lucia: 拿到拿到那个桌子上吧
Lucia: Put it on the table
Lucia: 嗯好累
Lucia: Ugh, so tired
Alice:你现在要贴吗
Alice: Are you going to stick it now?
Lucia: 嗯我想想我现在贴也可以
Lucia: Hmm, I think I can do it now
Lucia: 我要下去把那个拿一个充电宝
Lucia: I need to go get a power bank
Lucia: 嗯这个放过去
Lucia: Okay, put this over there
Lucia: 然后然后应该就可以贴了
Lucia: Then we should be able to stick it
Lucia: 就是我房子还有点还有点乱
Lucia: My place is still a bit messy.
Lucia: 我觉得我现在这样进去
Lucia: I feel like if I go in right now,
Lucia: 这个眼镜就会录到我房子很乱
Lucia: these glasses will record how messy my house is.
Lucia: 这个镜头
Lucia: This camera,
Lucia: 但是哈哈哈
Lucia: but hahaha
Lucia: 但好像也没有办法
Lucia: but it seems there's no way around it.
Lucia: 我睡衣啥都在床上撂着呢
Lucia: My pajamas and everything are just thrown on the bed.
Lucia: 起来完全没有收拾
Lucia: I didn't tidy up at all after waking up.
Lucia: 乱七八糟
Lucia: It's such a mess.
Lucia: （歌词）and it doesn't seem to matter
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it doesn't seem to matter
Lucia: （歌词）and it doesn't seem
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it doesn't seem
Lucia: （歌词）cause i feel it's flushing do i cry in lonely night
Lucia: (Lyrics) cause I feel it's flushing do I cry in lonely night
Lucia: （歌词）don't you judge my compulsion cause i'm lying to myself
Lucia: (Lyrics) don't you judge my compulsion cause I'm lying to myself
Lucia: 呃哦
Lucia: Uh oh
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah